[Music]
sarah's starting this hour off in
charlotte hi sarah how are you
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up in your world
um so i just wanted to ask um so my
husband and
both full-time college students and
we're going to be
seniors in the fall and i was just
wondering um
whether or not you would suggest we go
ahead and pay off our student loan
with extra scholarship money that we're
expecting to be refunded to us
usually no your husband and you changes
the conversation a little bit
you're both going to be seniors in the
fall so you've got one year
left and how is the fall how's the last
year for both of you being paid for
all scholarships yeah so after we got
married we
qualified for more financial aid and so
the scholarship money that we had was
more
than what it cost for tuition okay how
much more
um for this um upcoming school year
we're expecting about 13 000
per semester on top of your yeah
you're expecting how and how are you
eating
um well my husband works full-time as
well oh
okay cool very good and so what does he
make
um about 30. okay all right
um out of an abundance of caution no i
would just pile it up
and wait to wait to start your baby
steps until graduation
because both of you will graduate next
year at this time
and both of you hopefully will embark on
much better careers than either one of
you have ever seen before agreed
so your pay should go up way up this
time next year
is that right right okay at that point
i want you to more than anything added
no more debt
if you have 26 000 laying around
and have no more debt and have two big
jobs and you start your debt you start
your baby steps
you're going to throw that 26
immediately at the student loans and the
only thing you will have lost
was how much you would have paid off
between or how much interest you would
have saved between
now and this time next year
and uh really you may not even be
accruing interest yet are you
no not yet well we did for all of our
student loans are from our
freshman year yeah um so we have
interest all the way up until
last year when they suspended that yeah
but but and it should go back on in
september so
uh i think that's when it comes back on
if i remember so you're gonna have a
little interest
with my idea but that's okay i would
rather the big
thing is for sarah and her husband to
graduate with no more debt
and i want this cash as an insurance
policy to graduate with no more debt
then when you quote unquote start your
careers
following graduation one year from now
and you get the big jobs now we're going
to really push
play on the baby steps get going hard on
it and we're going to clean out any cash
we've got except a thousand dollars it's
not retirement money
we're going to throw it at your debts
which would obviously be your student
loans and or any other debts you have
don't take out any more debt
use this 26 000 to ensure that that
happens
that's the first goal it's kind of a
almost like the doctor's oath
hypocrite hippocratic oath do no harm
do no more harm is what this is don't
just don't allow yourself to go further
into debt and that's a cool position to
find yourself
in that suddenly um scholarship money
falls from the sky
yeah that's outstanding yeah well you
went and got it that's good too which a
lot of people just kind of wander along
don't even bother i mean if you quit
going through school like you take
too much xanax then you probably could
people just wander through like they're
in a haze
and in her case to her credit they got
married went hey maybe there's some
oh let's go get some money i don't know
if i ever told you dave the number of
scholarship committees i sat on that
went un
spent because we didn't have any
applications for the money this is
internal scholarship money at the
university where i was an administrator
so how would they have found
that money we would announce please
obviously but i mean
would they would they oh so they should
just know to go and apply
well donors will donate right a million
dollars and it rolls off the interest
out of the endowment so there's a
thousand dollar scholarship here and we
would make an announcement
after an announcement please apply for
this scholarship here's a list of them
where would they apply
they would go with the individual
committee no you'd go online to a
central place and write your um
for any scholarships available correct
for the university
and it's there's not only the university
but your particular college within the
university right
and they just we would sit there and say
well we can't we didn't have an
application for this one or this one or
this one or this one or one
savvy student would apply for all of
them and then we'd have to have the hard
cop do we give them all to one student
or first
let it sit there let it sit there in a
crew again right so just
like you said it's easy to put all your
eggs in that
scholarship basket as a freshman and
then you take your foot off the gas
man if you look every year man it never
sees well
anytime something changes like now we're
like old married people and we're
college students now that's a whole
bunch of scholarships which is what
happened with her
somebody donated money for marriage
students and
architecture program who fill in the
blank phenomenal yeah